[موسيقى]
مسلسل اخبار اهلا بكم اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان مقاطعه موسكو تعرضت لهجوم
الاوكراني بثماني طائرات مسيره وصفت هذا
الهجوم بالارهابي اضافه وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان دفاعات الجويه اسقطت خمس
مسيرات بمنظومه
من جهه قال عمده مدينه موسكو الهجوم
الاوكراني اسفر عن اصابه شخصين بجروح
طفيفه اما موقع ريبار العسكري الروسي فقال
ان الهجمات على موسكو وضواحيها تمت
باستخدام مسيرات اوكرانيه الصنع من طراز
22 هذا وقد افادت رويترز بان لجنه امنيه
روسيه بدات تحقيقات في سقوط طائرات مسيره
على مباني في موسكو
قالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان القصف
الذي تعرضت له العاصمه كيف وضواحيها فجر
اليوم نفذ باحدى وثلاثين مسيره من نوع
شاهد اسقطت الدفاعات الاوكرانيه 29 منها
وقالت الاداره العسكريه العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف ان شخصا قتل واصيب ثلاثه
اثره هجوم روسي واسع بالمسيرات على كييف
فجر اليوم وقالت انه هو الثالث من نوعه
خلال 24 ساعه
قال المستشار في الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ذا
الهجمات الروسيه الاخيره على كيف ومقاطعه
اخرى تهدف الى ارغام بلاده على القبول
بمبادره سلام تضعها موسكو
قلم راس الجزيره الانفجارا قويا دوا صباح
اليوم جنوب العاصمه السودانيه مترافقا مع
تحليق لطائرات حربيه كما فدى مراسل
الجزيره بسماع اصوات لاسلحه المضاده
للطائرات في ساعات الصباح الاولى وبتحليق
لطائرات حربيه جنوب مدينه
بعد ترحيب السعوديه والولايات المتحده
باتفاق القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات
الدعم السريع على تمديد اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار لمده خمسه ايام اخرى وذكرت وكاله
الانباء السعوديه ان الطرفي الهدنه على
مناقشه وقف اطلاق نار طويل الامد وعلى
ضروره اخلاء المستشفيات من الجهات المسلحه
قال دفع الله الحاج علي المبعوث الخاص
لرئيسه مجلس السياده في السودان للجزيره
ان الجيش السوداني قادر على الحسم واضاف
دفع الله ان الجيش لن يتفاوض مباشره مع من
وصفهم بالمتمردين
اعلن مكتب تنسيق المساعدات الانسانيه
تابعه للامم المتحده ان المواجهات المسلحه
في السودان اجبرت نحو مليون واربعمائه الف
شخص على النزوح الى مناطق داخل السودان
وخارجه
ابن الشباكات دارت بين الشرطه ومواطنين من
القوميه الصربيه حاولوا السيطره على مبنى
بلديه
وفد مراسل الجزيره بسماع اصوات انفجارات
جراء القاء قنابل الصوت والغاز المسيل
الدموع في محيط المكان بالاضافه الى طلقات
ناريه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]